hello folks
welcome to
rational science the only site on the
internet that does physics
everybody else does mathematics
what is mathematics well for this um to
understand that we got to go back
a few hundred years ago several hundred
years ago
and um you know when humanity started
out they
had to build buildings
and so people learned how to measure
and they developed what is known as
geometry one of the first
times that man applied
arithmetic or you could say the
beginnings of mathematics
and try to
uh
blend it with physics
and it was a rotten deal because they
got all the foundations wrong you know
what we know is geometry today
and
we receive our
information about geometry primarily
from the greeks
and here's uh what a famous greek said
about geometry or how high they the
greeks had it uh how high they esteemed
uh geometry and uh this is mr plato and
he said let no one ignorant of geometry
enter
and uh
or something to that effect there's the
sign
and uh so geometry was held in high
esteem and if you didn't know geometry
you were wet and ignoramus and they
would not let you in the club
nothing has pretty much changed in the
last 2 500 years
um
well we do it a little differently here
that's why you know that's known as
mathematics because they have all the
foundations wrong
uh they have the point and the line
primarily as the underlying you could
call them structures figures
they figures but that's what they have
as a foundation okay
yeah and you know this is the foundation
of uh g uh geometry and uh this is the
foundation of mathematical physics
and um
we we have something different we
propose something different and it's not
let no ignorant of geometry enter we
have something different here that's
what we propose instead
said let no one unless blind and
quadriplegic enter
if you use your eyes if you use your
hands
uh we're gonna rip them off okay
you're not allowed to use your hands or
your eyes
in physics okay so this is where we
start so we do it a little differently
than
mr plato suggested here okay
and so yeah
we have a different way of approaching
things we're saying you do not need to
know geometry you do not need to know
any math
because math can only describe
and what we're saying is we're going to
be explaining
specifically in physics we're going to
be explaining mechanisms okay
and so uh these are a series of words
that uh people who are not very smart
use
and we
discourage them
or else
okay
and here it is uh here is a list of
words that some people we call idiots
you know people who are very bright you
know exceedingly bright they're
enlightened and they have big big ideas
so we call them idiots from the word
those are the words if anyone uses any
of those words
uh
he's not doing physics at all he's doing
some kind of religion okay
and some of them are um
used as physical objects
and others are things that
they do that they think are related to
physics okay
and they're not
so if you find your word in there
one that you use to make your case
because i i mentioned these words
constantly okay but not to make my case
that's the point okay but people uh use
these words you know energy and mass and
field and time and so on to make their
case
to explain a mechanism of physics
and we're saying that's irrational okay
you can't use any of those words in
physics if you use them to make your
case
well look at the top end you'll find out
where you stand okay you're a very very
exceedingly bright individual okay and
if you don't know why
well that's
because you never went to
kindergarten physics you didn't take the
abcs you didn't learn them
okay
and so
some of the words there that
are typically used by
people who object or who oppose
the establishment mathematical physics
for example the electric universe okay
and what these people use is words such
as plasma and electricity and ether and
vortex
those are typical words in their mouths
and uh so if you use any of those well
now you know where you stand okay
that's where you belong
okay you cannot use those words as
physical objects
and you know i've had situations where
you know uh the electric universes said
what do you mean bill you're saying that
plasma is not a a thing
yeah exactly that's what i'm saying
plasma is not a thing
what do you mean huh electricity is not
a thing exactly imagine the electric
universe electricity which is part of
their name is not a thing
what do you mean it's not a thing stick
your fingers in the outland you'll find
out whether it's a thing
so this is how they prove
in the electric universe
how i think what a thing is you know you
say what is a baseball bat and they say
well let me show you
and they grab a baseball bat and hit
themselves on the head see if you can
hit yourself on the head it's a thing
that's more or less the logic these
people use and they so they say if you
want to
prove to yourself that electricity is a
thing stick your fingers in an outlet
so this is how they do it in the
electric universe well we don't do it
like that in science and again you got
to take kindergarten physics you could
call it physics 101
and so you learn you know what a thing
is
and what a none thing is okay
uh you have to be able to distinguish
first day of class okay you should be
able to distinguish between concepts and
objects he who cannot
is not a physicist he's just wasting his
time okay so the first
rule of the game is to distinguish
things from concepts okay and that's
what the electric universe has never
done neither has the establishment for
that matter okay
okay so um
now here we have uh
some of the people in the electric
universe if you start using some of
those words you're gonna end up in
electric universe prison
you'll never get out you'll be running
around the circles constantly why
because here it is these are their
famous words okay you have the
things such as the
vortex and you have uh
the waves they have all kinds of waves
transfers waves spherical waves
electricity this these are the words
they're going to fill you with
and there you have the famous
plasma ball okay
yeah these are the things that surround
you and keep you imprisoned in electric
universe prison okay so if you don't
want a life sentence there you know get
away from all of these words none of
these have anything to do with physics
or with science
okay
moving on here um
here we have a couple examples of people
who
think they are
very bright
very
exceedingly bright exceedingly
enlightened okay
one file says
the pull is to the known point in
counter space oh counter space
talking about magnets here how a magnet
attracts another says the pool okay is
towards counter space
okay between two magnets their forces
combine before they join
there's no magic
so far it sounds like magic to me i
don't know what this counter space is
the only kind of space i recognize is
you know when i put my beer on the
counter at the bar you know
if uh if there's too many bottles and
things here then i have no counter space
but if i can place my beer there then i
have counter space okay so that's the
way i look at it and uh you know here
you have a
a vision of that okay uh what this
fellow is saying he's saying that you
combine and join the forces so what is
it that he's combining and and uh
joining what forces there's only push
and pull
so is he saying that he's combining push
with pull somehow or maybe two pushes or
two pulls is that how two magnets come
together
okay so again it's it's these irrational
uh explanations that these people give
for common phenomena that really boggle
the mind okay
and uh here's another fella who also
uh
introduces counter space okay he says
counter space is small scale relative to
large scale right so it's small
we have a counter space which is small
you have counter space i guess that is
large i don't know
it is the inverse of space
okay so space is that black stuff
i guess right that's between the earth
and the moon
so counter space is what
means space is nothing right is he
saying that counter space is something
is a thing
what is counter space he says don't
worry about it not accomplishing it
don't worry about it
that's how he dismisses it
he's got no problem with counter space
he just uses words he doesn't even know
what he's talking about you could be
talking about x y or z it's an x what's
an x what's the opposite over y oh okay
and what is a y well don't worry about
it's not important anyways
okay yeah so here's a definition that
i've got i think for counter spaces
space left on the counter after one mug
of beer is placed on it okay
so that's what i think counter space is
yeah these people use these words and uh
they never define them uh we have this
fellow out there you know the
uh who i call the buddha okay and he has
his little show and he talks about conor
space constantly put it in his book
and
i mean you know i looked around his book
to find out what counter space is and
all he's got is either synonyms or buret
or irrationalities he always ends up
with the word field
which is nonsense you saw that one of
the first words there in uh in the list
at the beginning here of my talk today
field you don't want to use the word
field okay you can't say field that this
this does this or does that you can't
use the word field at all in any way
shape or form
okay so uh don't tell me counter space
is a field which is the opposite of
space and
all these guys just chase their tails
around okay
so um
uh
give me a second here
yeah so what is science about i mean if
these guys aren't doing science what is
science well here's a summary okay
uh in science the first word we have to
define is the word definition we have to
know what a definition is okay and you
have to define the word definition
scientifically okay so that's the first
one if you can't do it well you can't
even begin to do science okay
and a lot of people you know dismiss all
that say hey you know i came here to do
science not semantics and yeah poor
fellows
you know
this is not grammar this is not semantic
this is uh
presenting the foundations of science
that's what we're doing here okay so you
have to
set or you have to formulate the
foundations of science that's what it's
about and definition is one of the words
you need to define you need to know what
a scientific definition is okay
and then in physics which is a branch of
science okay
uh the first word you need to define is
an object you need to know what an
object is
okay and you have to distinguish it from
concepts okay
uh why because we can't do physics
without an object there's no phenomenon
that can occur there's no phenomenon
that you can explain unless you put an
object on the screen or use it in some
way in your presentation you need an
object to do physics without objects
there would be nothing happening in the
universe okay so you need a thing
for that you need to know what a thing
is you need to define it
okay uh and again because you're going
to be explaining a mechanism right a
cause
what is the purpose of physics is to
explain how the universe works by how we
don't mean a description we mean an
explanation okay we need to have a
physical interpretation of how the
universe works you need to explain what
is the mechanism the cause of gravity
for example or
how a magnet attracts another meaning
the cause what's making that happen okay
and uh so physics
is unrelated to mathematics in physics
we do not use mathematics mathematics is
not the language of physics the language
of physics is illustration and to
illustrate you need an object and that's
that's what we
preach here okay
and physically we don't do experiments
we don't do any measurements okay so
anyone doing measurements experiments
all they're doing is descriptions okay
we need to explain the results of an
experiment that's what we do in physics
but to take a measurement anybody can
measure a table even a 10 year old does
that make him a physicist because he can
measure a table because he ran an
experiment he doesn't understand what he
did he just poured one liquid into
another and they turned from red to blue
and he doesn't understand what happened
he just oh i did an experiment
great i mean you know does that mean you
understood that you can explain
something
so no we don't do experiments or
measurements what we do is explain the
results of experiments you have to
explain the experiment the cause
not do it
and uh the second word you need to
define in physics which is important
which is exist okay you need to know
what exists means because exist is the
science of existence
the reason these atheists and agnostics
go around in circles and have been going
around in circles for who knows how long
is because none of them ever defined the
word exist to this day we have no
definition of the word exist all you
will find in the dictionaries are
synonyms and long explanations like if
you go to the uh
stanford
encyclopedia philosophy oh man they'll
talk about exist until you die and no
and
at no point do they define it they
cannot tell you what exist means and
they never have that's why people are
still wondering you know does god exist
do you believe in god and
they keep going around in circles in
science is very simple we define the
word exist if it meets the definition
it exists by definition it exists
pursuant to the definition that's how
straightforward it is
anyways we had this uh fellow who
criticized my
science uh series that i started
and we'll get to him in a minute first i
want to
mention
the
uh who the winner this week is for the
idiot honor roll talking about idiots
hey we have the idiot honor roll and it
was a big competition this week i mean
people tried very hard to win and uh i
gave it to this only because
he mentioned something that several
people have mentioned along the way we
have a little history on on this issue
and so i thought i'd put them up there
in light so that people understand it
okay so what did this spell say see if i
can get uh this here
give me a second
okay well it says
in the rope theory
okay not a theory it's a hypothesis but
okay
what is the explanation for the cause of
the pull down to the earth okay
if everything is connected by ropes
electromagnetic ropes right
why is it that all the ropes that
connect to other stars planets don't
also pull on objects
okay there's several people who said you
know they said you know when the
spoon falls
say i say well because the spoon is
connected to the every atom of the spoon
is connected to every atom you know in
the earth that that comprises the earth
and so the question is you know they say
this says well how about the ropes that
connect us to everything else in the
universe don't they pull the spoon
upwards should they
and i guess that's why you win the prize
this week okay so let's go slowly for
for those who have problems now there's
two possibilities
the the fellow either jumped the gun
okay and just uh
said ask the question without thinking
or maybe he actually doesn't understand
and it's simply an ignoramus i guess he
never went to high school because in
high school they teach you something
called mathematical physics okay
and one of the first things you learn is
newton's equation
don't they understand that newton's
equation don't they relate to it at all
okay so this is what it's all about here
you have
the earth the moon and an astronaut over
there on the right okay and the
astronauts close to the earth
okay so the question is who would he be
attracted to uh to the earth or the moon
you said you might say well to the earth
because it's bigger it's got more mass
okay that's what newton's equation would
say
but how about the distance you know like
under the rope model you have all these
uh connections from the astronaut to the
moon to the earth okay
and
you also have connection from the
astronaut to the uh moon okay here it is
okay
so
he's connected to both the moon and the
earth by electromagnetic roads but now
you look at the equation and you
hopefully should be able to determine
that it's not mass that's written the
big uh
ingredient in the equation it's that
distance squared on the bottom
you know distance plays an enormous role
in that equation the more distance you
have you know mass can become even
almost irrelevant it doesn't matter how
big the mass is if it's on the other
side of the universe okay you will have
no effect on that mass because the
distance is so great
and uh here you have for example in this
case you have a star okay
and uh it's it's far away okay
and every uh atom in that star is tied
or bound to every atom in your body in
every single atom you know they're all
connected
and but it's so far away that you can
almost consider
um
all those ropes as a single coaxial
as if it were a single thread
you know it's got very little influence
to you even though every atom in your
body is connected to every atom of that
uh star and the reason you can see the
star is that you're looking along the
ropes in other words the rope torques
from that atom in that star to an atom
in your eye and that's why you can see
it
otherwise you know how do you think uh
mother nature does this does it do it
without anything between your eye
and that star
are you saying that we have this far
away started sending little photons to
your eye
don't those photons swerve in the in
space
okay don't they
turn around the corner
according to einstein you know you've
got all these
potholes
caused by gravity
and should
those photons just go in every which way
except straight
okay so here we're saying no
you have a straight line of direction to
that star and you have it through the
ropes so you have you know
the situation you know i'm connected to
every atom in your body through the
ropes
okay so and that the ropes are always
taut they're tight okay pull tight
not flexible
okay and all they do is torque in place
that's why they're so fast because
torsion is the fastest thing known to
man
and uh so that's our theory but yeah you
have to apply newton's equation
and for that you got to look at distance
so
yeah uh people who ask that question
will
can look at the
honor roll and maybe they'll find their
answer there okay
okay let's go with the science fellow uh
he
he said the other days
he criticized my
theory and he was looking at the word
hypothesis he was saying
that uh hypothesis need to be tested
okay let's listen to his own words okay
they can come out of his own mouth so
i'm gonna set this in motion here give
me a second here goes listen carefully
here goes
questions and issues addressed in this
rebuttal are
what is a hypothesis
and
is a hypothesis testable
you need to be able to formulate a
hypothesis and that hypothesis needs to
be testable and then you have to test
that hypothesis
okay so you're saying we have to test
the hypothesis
how do you test the hypothesis
well before we can test it we have to
figure out what a hypothesis is then
maybe we can decide how we're going to
test it
with an experiment i mean i don't know
let's find out let's find out what a
hypothesis is first okay
and so we look at the word we look it up
and we find all these versions here that
it's a purpose a question a tentative
guess
punch
uh
talking about a prediction also it's an
assumption an explanation
uh you present evidence for him so you
can test it i guess right
it's a theory a provisional explanation
a tentative theory you know uh and
another file says data analysis
i mean are all these synonyms that
hypothesis is everything
what the hell is a hypothesis i mean you
know uh here i um
summarize it for you okay uh will the
real hypothesis please stand up okay
because they have all these versions of
what a hypothesis is
you know i think they lost track of what
they're talking about after a while okay
and so the question is you know is a
hypothesis the same thing as a purpose
and if it's as a purpose is it the same
thing as a prediction
if it's not a prediction you know then
uh
what is it
what are we talking about here you know
we got a real problem here because you
know they have all these versions of
what a hypothesis is
okay uh is uh is an assumption the same
thing as an explanation is a
question the same thing as a tentative
guess
i mean you know they have all these
versions you know what is a hypothesis
and i i can tell you right now
mathematics has no idea what a
hypothesis is
they have so many versions of it that
people have lost track of what a
hypothesis is
but uh most people define it as this and
and these are uh definitions you'll find
out there okay most of them essentially
say that it's a
tentative explanation this is more or
less where most people converge upon
when they officially or
you know define the word hypothesis
there you see
all the versions okay
okay so is that what um what a
hypothesis is
is um
you know just all these uh
versions of explanations possible
explanations or proposed explanations
etc well when you do a scientific uh
dictionary there britannica you know it
says uh hypothesis differs fundamentally
from theories
my god uh they're saying it's a theory
over here on the left and on the right
they're saying oh by the way you know
it's different okay let's see what's
different about them says whereas the
former is a specific tentative
explanation serves as the main tool by
which scientists gather data
the latter is a broad general
explanation that incorporates data from
many different scientific investigations
so i guess what they're saying here is
that in one case it's an explanation
from one fella
or collector from information or data
that he collected in his basement
and
the other explanation the theory that's
from many basements
great i mean is this the difference one
basement versus many basements is that
what the difference between a hypothesis
and a theory
okay so we have a problem there um and
then to top it off we have this fellow
and uh let me
know got the wrong way hold it i have
this spell here
and uh he's from a university he's a
emeritus professor
and his name is donald simonek and he
says science doesn't explain
science describes
because that's what math can do that's
the only thing math can do describe
and so if science doesn't explain you
know we started out saying what is a
hypothesis it's an explanation a
tentative explanation they have all
these versions actually you know so it's
a prediction it's a uh an assumption
it's a data collection who knows what
else
then they say well no no it's it's an
explanation different kinds of
explanation but it's an explanation
great
and now they say well there's a
difference between explanation and
hypothesis one hypothesis one guy has
explanation what many people have
apparently that's what it's all about
one versus many now this guy said oh by
the way we don't explain anything
so we went full circle what did you
learn today in school son not much
okay so we don't know what a hypothesis
is but if it's an explanation as well
says we don't explain
so
at this point i don't know what science
is about if science is about explaining
or about testing hypotheses and uh
and hypothesis explanation and we don't
explain great
okay okay but let's assume that it's an
explanation and this vowel says we're
gonna test that we should test the
hypothesis okay let's test it let's see
how we're going to test it and here's an
example this is um
general relativity gravity under general
relativity okay
and these are confirmations of the
explanations for gravity according to
you know general relativity these are
things that they claim they confirmed
through experiments
okay so general relativity they say is
the most confirmed theory out there you
know and it's confirmed by all these
experiments
okay let's
let's find out let's
uh listen to what these people have to
say so here's the first one okay
mercury's perihelion shift okay and it's
what you find out there it says
mercury's very healing shift einstein's
1915 general theory accounted for
mercury's anomalous recession
einstein wrote to michael basil
perihelion motions explained
quantitatively
you will be astonished
yeah i'm already astonished because i
don't know how you can explain
quantitatively
you know what does that mean you either
explain or you describe quantitative is
only descriptions so i guess uh einstein
didn't understand the difference between
an explanation and description either
okay
and then in general relativity this
change of orientation of the orbital
ellipse within its orbital plane is
explained by gravitation being mediated
by what the curvature of time
the curvature of time there you see a
warp time
so they're explaining the orbit of
uh
mercury
by saying that time has curvature time
has been warmed time is bent
as this fall said the other day
um is this what it's all about saying
that uh is this does this sound rational
to you to say that time is bent time is
work that explains why mercury rolls
around
in these ellipses shifting ellipses
i mean does this make any sense how did
how did they confirm that
uh observation experiment you know uh
testing the hypothesis is that's how
they did it
let's move on light bending
gravitational lensing this is another
confirmation of relativity let's see how
they did this one that's got to be fun
okay here it is okay light bending
the bending of light is in gravitational
fields all this from um from the
wikipedia by the way experiments showing
light bending in accordance with the
predictions of general relativity were
performed in 1919.
okay i don't know what experiment they
could have done or what predictions
these were but how do you bend light
einstein became the first to calculate
the correct value of light bending and
as after newton you know gravity
predicts that starlight will bend around
a massive object
so how do you bend a wave transverse
wave
assuming that's what you know because
they're saying that these uh gravity
they talk about gravitational waves so
how do you bend these waves and how do
you bend photons assuming you know
photons are the same thing as gravitons
or vice versa and you have all these
particles it could be either photons
gravitons or any particle muons if you
want i mean or
higgs
you know how do you how do you bend
these things if we're talking about
particles or waves how do you bend them
okay so so again i don't know how they
proved this they say these are the
confirmations that they prove that
through experiments how do you prove
that you're going to bend light how do
you going to prove that you bend gravity
how are you going to prove that you bend
magnetism
what sense does any of that make how do
you do that how do you test the
hypothesis
okay uh they do space bending okay let's
find out what that's all about space
bending that's got to be fun here it is
uh
if you want anything bent you should
call on i need service okay he he bends
anything he bends bananas hammocks
whatever you got okay here's his
einstein theory suggested that large
objects bend the space around them
okay i don't know how you can bend space
if it's not a physical object but this
is the way they treat it
massive celestial bodies like the earth
drag their local space time around with
them as they rotate that comes out of
nasa
okay how do gravity probe be uh
experiment by the way and so the
question is how does the earth drag a
concept such as time around
you know what sense does this make how
did they prove that and he said well
they sent some gyroscopes there and they
moved
okay so the gyroscopes moved and
so they inferred
they didn't prove anything they inferred
that
the gyroscopes moved oscillated or
whatever moved out of their position
because they rubbed their elbows against
space
how did they do that
no they made an assumption that space is
a physical object and the gyroscope
rubbed its you know elbow against the uh
this thing called space
or time maybe maybe you know it was
against time that it scripted its elbow
i mean what sense does it sense make to
say that they confirmed experimentally
that earth drags time around itself
what is this this is nonsense or space
it doesn't really matter
okay how about uh time bending time oh
man that's got to be just as good okay
here it is
and you know he he bends the seconds uh
good old line e there strong men on e
does gravity bend time in quora the
answer says if i answer he says if you
consider time and space to be the same
thing then yes and that's what hawking
told us he says in relativity there is
no real distinction between the space
and time coordinates okay
and then in a stack exchange another
prominent site who supposedly does
at least mathematical physics okay
gravity is the bending of
time
yeah these people spend time how did
they confirm all this how did they test
this hypothesis when you cannot even
make sense of it i mean before you do an
experiment hopefully you do a design of
experiment and this fellow is saying go
test the hypothesis
how do you test a hypothesis such as
that you're going to bend time or you're
going to bend space or you're going to
warp the uh
field or or bendy or you know curve the
wave or a series of gravitons or photons
particles how do you do this
what conformations are there how do you
test the hypothesis
please give me a mechanism how you test
the hypothesis and we're going to find
out whether you uh did anything physical
whether you explained anything
rationally okay that's that's the issue
so now we don't test hypothesis whatever
that means
okay um
why haven't these people zeroed in you
know the mathematicians mathematicians
mathematics why haven't they
ever figured out gravity
well they haven't figured out not only
gravity but any of the invisible
intangible
uh
phenomena out there you know you you
have gravity you have magnetism you have
electricity the atom you can't see in
there it's so tiny or
simply you know like in the case of
magnetism i always show this two magnets
right the two little circles there and
uh you can see that there's there's
absolutely nothing between them okay
nothing that you can touch or see
and you can just do this at home i mean
you don't have to believe what i'm
saying here i'm just saying
put your hand between two magnets you
won't feel or see anything
okay so how do you test that
do you go to the lab and do what please
tell me what experiment you can think of
in which you're going to detect what
magnetism is what that invisible
mediator looks like that's what we're
trying to find out
and uh so here let me show you uh a
couple of things here that you can see
what the problem was
for the last 2500 years why they haven't
figured any of this out
here you see a chariot okay fellow
charioteer and he's uh
he's got his horse tied to to to his
buggy there okay his little chariot
and so we understand it we look at and
we say well why does the chariot move
uh together with a horse
and you say well because somehow the
horses the horse is bound to the chariot
or the chariot bound to the horse
they're in physical contact that's why
this is not surprising that we're used
to these kinds of things every day you
know and we look at this and we say okay
i understand it i don't need to go to
college to understand why the cart moved
there okay
okay so uh here let's look at it again
now here's this situation
okay
and now you say well why is the cart
moving now
whoa that's scary i mean
you know how is it that the horse is
pulling on the cart
assuming that's what's happening right
maybe something's pushing on the cart
from behind but we don't see anything in
front or behind the cart
so why is the cart moving together with
a horse
and so people have problems here because
they say oh man this this is weird this
is out of this world i can't see your
touch
if you were there right uh you know
whatever's the bomb between the horse
and the charioteer there or the or the
chariot right
you know you can't see
what's connecting them
and so this is when it becomes really
scary so let's look at it again side by
side okay or up and down okay
on the top you have um
the one that's connected and on the
bottom you have one that's not connected
and the top one we have no problem
understanding and accepting the problem
we have is with the bottom one
okay and so this is the issue the issue
is the only reason you cannot explain
gravity the only reason you cannot
explain magnetism is you cannot see the
invisible things that
are mediating between two magnets or
between the earth and the spoon in case
of the spoon falling to earth
gravity
and so
and all you have to do is do what you
see here you once you make the reigns
you know and so on the
uh thing that's connecting the uh horse
to the
buggy there
uh once you make that visible then it's
not a mystery it's kid stuff you don't
need math you don't need to go to
college you can just look and say okay i
can explain that it's it's tied you know
that's why the card's moving the only
reason you would not be able to is if
you have the bottom situation where you
don't have
a connection between the horse and the
charioteer
okay so this is the issue the issue is
that
the only reason these people have been
stumped throughout history of why
the spoon falls to earth is because they
can't see or touch the mediators
why have they they've been stumped by
magnetism you know
because they can't see or touch the
mediators
if you make the mediators visible
and show a mechanism of how it's done
now people say
that's kid stuff anybody can understand
that
the only reason is you can't see the
mediators period we're done okay so
there's nothing to test what are you
gonna test as far as
something that is invisible or
intangible
i mean this
individual says go and test the
hypothesis okay we go to the lab what do
you want me to do
how am i supposed to test the hypothesis
here okay
what am i supposed to do please tell me
how you would test
the hypothesis the hypothesis is what
that particles what was it green pixies
attract these two things great
show me in the lab
uh or wherever you want to test it i
mean i don't know uh show me how a
magnet attracts another or how a pencil
you know falls to earth
okay
uh
with pixies whatever you want particles
waves
show me the mechanism test the
hypothesis all you want then come back
and tell me this is how what the
mechanism is tell me how it was done how
the magic trick was done that's what we
want to understand okay
yeah so these are my conclusions okay
um hypothesis is not a theory
it's not a theory
hypothesis is
an assumption an assumption is not an
explanation which is what a theory is
okay
and uh description is not an explanation
and i talked about that in the past i'll
be talking about more of that in the
future but right now i'm not going to
get into that but now anyone who thinks
that an explanation is a series of
descriptions well he's got something
else coming and he should go to square
number one what was it the idiot uh
honor roll there and find out if uh if a
description is the same thing as a
uh
explanation
okay explanation what is it it's a
mechanism you have to explain the cause
okay you what is the explanation in
physics right it's a physical
interpretation what caused something to
happen
it's not how in the sense of
let me describe it for you no it's how
in the sense of let me explain it how it
worked what caused it to happen that's
what a mechanism that's what a mechanism
is and that's what physics is about
explaining the mechanism that's known as
a physical interpretation but even
assuming we concede to this phone say
okay you're going to test the hypothesis
fine and what is a hypothesis well i
guess he's going to say it's an
explanation of some kind a tentative one
whatever i don't care but it's an
explanation one way or another i don't
care what adjective you put in front or
adverb okay fine so the first issue is
verification assuming we go in there and
we falsify we test we verify
all you did was believe you changed
someone's belief
okay you just changed his opinion
you haven't
done any more than that you just gave
them your opinion your version you say
i tested the hypothesis okay you tested
it great
what did you come out with well i came
up with this
and what you're telling the fella is i
want you to believe in my theory
i want you to believe in my hypothesis
in in the way i explain this
and the guy says yeah this guy believes
in this guy doesn't so all you did was
affect belief
science is not belief so we don't test
hypothesis even if a hypothesis is an
explanation
and even if you tested it
you know all you did was try to convince
something of your version of events
that's all you did okay and then you
know with all these
uh tests experiments what did he came up
come up with they came up with
irrational explanations physical
interpretations for the ones that i just
mentioned you know uh gravity uh
primarily uh in this case you know and
um
what have they done they have what have
they explained by saying space-time is
war
is that a rational explanation so here
they tested the hypothesis
they went out there they did the
experiment they say we confirmed
uh that the hypothesis was tested that
it was
verified i don't know what the language
is in mathematics okay so you did all
that what did you come up with well they
came up with warp time
that's gravity warp time great
seconds are warped the minutes are
worked the years are worth
what kind of explanation is that it's
irrational totally so all their testing
all their experiments only led them to
irrational irrational explanation two
irrationalities okay and uh you can't
test
you know if you're going to test the
explanation you can't test
what is invisible
and intangible you know magnetism
gravity you can't test that
all you can do is make an assumption of
what you think is in there what physical
object is mediating the transaction and
based on that assumption you give an
explanation so that someone understands
the mechanism
okay that we can all follow
but uh
other than that you know uh what are you
gonna test what experiment you're gonna
run uh for this again here's the
experiment this is the only experiment
you need for gravity you let go of the
pencil and it falls down
okay here on earth
okay so it falls downwards great
that's the only experiment you you did
you did the experiment now come back and
tell us why
that's what you got to do but to say
that you did the experiment i let go of
the pen a million times to make it very
you know a repeatable verifiable
yeah so
i measured i know the speed great and
any any uh what idiot can do that
no we want a scientist we want someone
who can explain
what caused the pencil to fall downwards
and
no so we don't need to test the
hypothesis what we do in science we
visualize we attempt to visualize
the mechanism and for that you know all
you need to have is maybe a beer on your
right hand you're left-handed you can
use your left i guess
and visualize you know try to imagine
how mother nature could be doing these
magic tricks i mean how would you do it
if you go and see watch a magician on on
stage he cuts the lady in half or does
something with balloons and uh and um
you know doves
takes a handkerchief maybe and dove
comes out
makes a magic trick
and you say oh man how did he do that
and okay and so you try to figure out
how he did it that's how you do it
what are you gonna go there with a
measuring run say let me measure this
okay i'm going to measure the the hanky
that you use i'm going to measure the
dove see if he fits in there and i mean
you know no the way you do it you sit
down there
with the audience you try to visualize
how the guy could have done the trick
and that's how that's how science works
that's how physics works you have to try
to figure out how the universe works
as an as a spectator the only way you
can do that for invisible intangible
things is
visualizing okay
so
starting tomorrow everybody
try to visualize
okay let's get to some of the mornings
okay we got muniz who's a muni muni is a
person who thinks we didn't go to the
moon
and the other day i sort of
started becoming a moony a little bit
why because they made me or they asked
me to watch a
documentary three hour documentary that
went over all the different uh aspects
that the moonees say are
[Music]
evidence
that we did not go to the moon
and why
do i have doubts now and i'm not saying
that we went we didn't go to the moon
that we did go to the moon i still think
we did but i'm not a hundred percent
sure anymore
and the reason is very simple first of
all i'm open-minded and uh you know i'm
willing to consider other possibilities
i don't consider
whether
you know santa claus is in the north
pole i i don't think i'm going to make a
trip there to verify whether santa claus
is there or not okay
and i won't do it either because i'm
worried that i may actually find santa
claus you know with rudolph and dancer
and prince
when i come back they might put me away
okay so i'm worried about that i'm more
worried about finding santa than not
finding santa okay
so i don't go to to verify these things
i don't go to
you know to the flat earth to the edge
of the flat earth to find out if there's
a wall of ice there
and the
you know the militias
government militias or whatever you know
they're there to protect so that i won't
see the wall
no no i won't go to the antarctica just
to find out you know that the earth is
flat okay i don't do those things but
here's a different situation these
people uh presented their case
uh
some things which i cannot explain
okay
and
until i can explain i can't say that i'm
100 sure that we went to the moon
i think we did for other reasons which
i'll be discussing now but all i'm
saying is you know it does they did put
the little uh seed of doubt in me okay
on some things simply because i cannot
explain them myself okay
okay so uh one file says
he starts out he says uh
he says
make separate videos uh for such stuff
at at least even better a whole
different channel
in the chat we were saying that get back
on topic already what the hell is this
channel anyways you know irrational
conspiracies
well now uh we got to put in the right
perspective okay there are different
aspects to the mooney issue here they
are okay let me summarize them here
there's the politics and conspiracy
aspect of of this okay that's one issue
there's also the
you know you can criticize the
assumptions okay whether some of those
assumptions are correct or not so that's
a way of attacking the hypothesis in um
in your theory okay
what are the hypothesis the assumptions
that you make okay
and then there's the
scientific aspect the theories
etc you know where you have you know how
did we get to the moon
um
you know did we have booster rockets
that took us there
uh even even if it was filmed let's
assume it was all a hoax okay
how did they do the filming isn't that a
valid question of physics because we're
talking about you know again not not the
political aspect there we're saying how
did they do the filming so that they
were able to convince you that we went
to the moon okay how did they do all
these tricks it's just like a magic
trick that you see the magician perform
on stage you try to figure out how he
tricked you
and and that is science you know you're
saying how did he do that i want to know
i want to understand that and this is
the same thing even if they fooled you
even if it's a hoax you might say okay
how did they do that okay so that part
is scientific so it's not all
just uh you know
conspiracy okay there are conspiracies
and are conspiracies okay and there are
several aspects of the moon landing
which are worthy of study from a
scientific perspective that's all i'm
saying okay and again i'm suggesting
people keep an open mind
okay why did i change my mind a little
bit and it's got to do uh
with this you know here let me show it
to you one more time okay uh
here it goes pay attention
listen carefully here it goes
then on september 16th they appear for a
press conference in front of the global
members of the press who welcomed them
with a standing ovation
everyone expects to see three absolute
heroes radiating with happiness and
pride for their incredible achievement
but their faces appear somber tense
somehow preoccupied instead
they seem uncomfortable and there are
several truly embarrassing moments
during the event when the three
astronauts are asked the meaning of a
mission that has brought mankind on
another celestial body for the first
time the three don't seem too eager nor
too enthusiastic about answering the
question many of us and many other
people in many places
have speculated on the meaning of this
first landing on another body in space
would each of you give us
your estimate of what is the meaning of
this to all of us
and when armstrong describes their
achievement as the beginning of a new
era he seems more like a person forced
to read from a script than someone
actually convinced of his own words the
entire program
it's
a beginning of
a new age
okay so
the way i look at this is
uh to me uh
they were ashamed
this this is the impress i mean i'm no
psychology i have no shrink but uh i can
tell you just my impression these people
are hiding something this is not the
attitude that you have when you went to
the moon and came back that's not the
gung-ho attitude that you're alive
because you came back here you have all
these people clapping and saying you
guys are hero and the guy are kind of
looking at themselves and saying you
know are we heroes
you know so this this was telling the
other one was the fact that you know
they chased after them to swear on the
bible none of them would
and then uh you know uh neil armstrong
has
appeared only in one reunion
and he was very somber again very
bad attitude there
shameful attitude if you ask me and he
never appeared again maybe because the
united states government did not invite
him
saying that this guy might spill the
beans he's just too obvious
so this this was very telling in my
opinion now one possibility is that
maybe you know uh
the first moon landing never happened
maybe then others happen but this for me
it was uh very important okay uh and let
me tell you why um
when uh when a detective
goes out to a crime scene
you know whether he's a private eye or a
police detective
you know
they suspect everyone
that's the way it works you're not
innocent you're not
innocent until proven guilty everybody
is considered a suspect until you can
eliminate them as a
as a suspect in other words until you
verify their alibis
and that's the way you should work this
issue as well you should leave all
pre-con conceptions aside
and look at it from a scientific point
of view strictly from a scientific point
of view
and one of the things that you know
detectives look at is you know the
attitude the person has you know they
just killed his wife and he says oh i
want someone to go look for this guy
and then he goes out and parties with
his girlfriend
you know and uh
what are you gonna say that the guy had
the right ad or he's got a you know an
attitude where he says well you know
yeah my wife died
you know it's not the right attitude the
right attitude that you should have that
you would think the guy has is oh my
poor wife she died she she was killed
you know those are normal reactions when
someone doesn't react in that way
yeah the detectives suspect a lot
you know
and so all i can tell you is this was a
bad reaction and this is on top of some
of the other things that happened in
there in that documentary like you know
the uh
to me okay that that i cannot explain
and that's like when the astronauts
pulled back suddenly you know like he
was lifted from some wires
in some cases they jumped too fast and
that's what it appears to me right now i
need to investigate that further i'm
gonna run it in slow motion to find out
if those jerky motions are correct if
they're
natural if they were done in a studio or
on the moon
there's also the dust
that the rovers you know
uh twirl around they say well that
shouldn't happen on the moon i don't
know if that's the case i gotta find out
that as well you know so there are
certain things that the documentary
mentioned that concern physics
you know and these are things that i
like to look at they do concern physics
okay um
so one fell says
he says bill since you were in search of
truth the truth is what is not hidden
oh man why do these people even come to
science no
truth has nothing to do with science
truth has to do with belief with
religion okay when you prove something
when you have the truth you're talking
about religion when you know it when you
know the truth you're talking about
religion okay
and uh then he continues he says uh
believing the u.s that u.s landings have
taken place is a leap of faith
okay to some degree that's true
and then he says i don't believe it's a
hoax i know for sure it's a hoax
and it reminds me of the three stooges
where they say uh do you think you can
make it work larry he says i don't know
i don't think i know
and moe says i don't think you know
either
so yeah and then you can see he says so
it puts you gullible as a believer okay
in front of a leap of faith
and me instead as a free thinker who has
analyzed tons of original nasa documents
and formed his own opinion on the matter
it turns out that he later says that
there are no uh original nasa documents
because they were all destroyed
so uh you know these people live with
these contradictions all they have is
emotions
and
that's a bad sign in science you really
when you're looking at these things you
have to look at it as a detective
everybody's guilty
okay until you can prove them innocent
okay and you should keep an open mind
you should go in there objectively and
you know it's very hard for people to do
that they have all these emotions in
them okay this is a problem
okay so he comes up with a series of
issues that are not
uh very solid but which are raised by
many moonies okay and here's uh some of
them okay uh official documents they're
lost and there's he says currently there
are only copies of the originals again
you know
how can he say that he
that he looked at originals and then he
says there's only copies
then uh it says that whether the
russians shared results with the
americans well you know they share a lot
of things out there you know they have
joint missions and it's like you know
there are things that are not top secret
okay so there's a lot of information
shared between the russians and the uh
and the americans out there in space
which have nothing to do with some
technical secrets
that uh one side can steal from the
other okay so it's
they do share information okay certain
information mining on the moon yes
that's future we
you know we can't talk about that right
now and whether there's been
no
trip to the moon in the last 50 years
again uh you know there are reasons for
that there's nothing there's no reason
to go to the moon and that's why they
never had to prepare anything in the
last 50 years to go back to the moon
you can't see the flag well you know
that's very easily solved very easily
they can put
a flag on the moon with a uh with a
an artificial mission they don't need to
put a an astronaut on the moon so the
next time they they go there they can
still put the old flag there in the same
place they say the flag's there so they
can fool you anyways okay so that's not
a way of proving
uh to anyone that you went to the moon
or not and then the power of the rock is
do we have uh power enough in the
rockets to send um you know rockets to
the moon
that's a valid issue that does concern
physics okay but i'm going to address a
couple other issues which have to do
with physics okay this is about physics
not about
uh really
uh you know your opinion
this has to do with something that we
should be able to test okay we can test
it here on earth the first one is
radiation okay did the russians send
turtles to
uh pass the two van allium radiation
belts twice you know back and forth
okay um so the question is you know
the russians did that a few months
before
the first moon landing or alleged
moon landing
um
you know the turtles came back alive
according to official versions right
russian and american by the way
and uh so this fella says uh you know he
says there the usa uh send human life
beyond the van allen radiation belts
without even a small mole grown or
without a tumor or with uh
classic symptoms of radiation
he thinks that if you sense something
alive like a turtle or a human
the uh thing should come back the this
living entity should come back with
cancer
and you know i think the expectations
the notions that people have about you
know
what radiation will do to you how fast
it will do it to you and at what dosage
it will do it to you
they haven't i think looked at that at
all okay this is where the problem is
and so he says van allen radiation belts
are impossible for humans to cross
is that is that the case
okay and so you know when you go to nasa
and to other sites this is uh these are
some of the papers you find out there
okay and i don't know if you read any of
these
but these are things that you would have
to read in order to answer these
questions okay and here's one says
radiation doses measured during apollo
were significantly lower than the yearly
average of a five rem set by the u.s
atomic energy commission
for workers who use radioactive
materials in factories and institutions
across the united states
and so they go through these numbers and
they say look these are the
the radiation doses that they would have
received they're way below the
uh
i think it's with the five rem average
vibram that would start causing problems
these are way below that level
and so to say that you know you're going
to have cancer because you
you know you pass the radiation belts uh
i think his expectations is what's uh
overblown okay
and here's nasa says the main
operational counter measures against the
adverse effects
of
radiation is simply limiting astronaut
exposure which means limiting the amount
of time astronauts are allowed to be in
space
okay this is accomplished primarily by
shortening overall mission duration on
the space station to three to six months
okay so they have these these different
uh
ways of protecting the astronauts some
of them involve uh protection some of
them involve time they also have this
suit which measures radiation
you know to see how much doses they
received and if they're they've been
zapped or whatever you know in a couple
months ago i went for an mri
and i asked the the gal who ran the uh
the machine i said um
uh do you do you are because they walk
outside right they leave you inside
to get zapped and so i asked her you
know
do you get radiation et cetera et cetera
and she said uh she told me a little bit
about it she says she she has a
radiation meter
and she every time she throughout the
day she carries it with it and so they
measure their radiation how much dose
she gets
and she says it's it's actually quite
normal you know because she's outside
there's radiation in the room she's in
that room constantly she goes back
outside maybe at some point she might
receive by mistake some radiation i
don't know but they monitor that and uh
she doesn't get cancer because of that
okay even the uh people in hiroshima and
nagasaki you know um
it's not a lot of them got cancer many
years later
it's not like they suddenly you know
start growing tumors all over unless
they rezab directly okay so
again these people have uh a poor notion
of how radiation actually works
but there are more basic things here's
another one okay the spell raised okay
he raised all the issues so i'm just
going to consider what he said
essentially because everybody raises the
same arguments okay says today we have a
tin of tuna you know tin can out there
orbiting the earth in low orbit because
humanity cannot do more than that okay
so we have this tuna
can up there okay it's called the iss
and the first thing i want to establish
yes that there is a can of tuna going up
there okay so here's a
this is a an amateur uh photographer
filmer i guess you could call him and uh
and he filmed the uh iss there's the iss
at night okay and that's what it looks
like in one of his photographs okay so
he says look you know i filmed this
thing
uh orbiting the earth up there in the
sky
okay and there's uh hundreds of amateur
astronomers on earth that film these
things and take pictures and so on and
like i said all you need to do is you
know here's another version of that okay
uh take your
binocular your uh
telescope whatever you have or your
friends right
and take a look and find out if there is
uh out there this this thing that you
see there the picture that this file
took which is the space station this iss
international space station
is this thing out there so if if you
confirm that there is such a space
station out there at least we got to say
okay there's this monster
500 miles out there right or i think 500
kilometers uh floating around the earth
how did we put that piece of metal
not a little tiny thing this is not a
little tin can this is a big monster
okay that's floating out there because
you can see it with your telescope you
can do the calculation how much you see
of it you can say okay that thing is big
that's a big that's not a kite okay
iss kite okay no that's a real station
that's floating out there how did we do
that did we do that all of a sudden and
we just go one day and
uh suddenly you know decide to send the
space station out there
no there had to be many steps in between
and among them you had to orbit the
earth
with some
vehicle of some kind
and you know when you look back yeah all
those steps were taken all the way to
even putting a man around
uh the
uh in orbit
the guard the first one who who went
into space around the earth and so you
know some people deny that
you know there's different level of uh
credulity or incredulity some people
don't believe this others believe less
others believe not at all and so you got
to go step by step very slowly
and so you know here's uh
one thing that this ball raises you know
because okay the tin cans floating out
there uh that's it uh they put that out
there to fool people that's a hoax okay
so he said do you think it's possible
that a woman
with hair fluttering in the air
releases dangerous molecules of water
inside the space uh base that orbits the
earth
he doesn't believe that this is true
what you what i'm going to show now
which this lady okay she's an astronaut
she's up there on the space station she
releases a big drop of water and then
she swallows it
and he says how would she do that that's
dangerous because you have all this
water floating could kill someone
so i mean is this guy for real i mean
does he really believe that this is
going to kill someone because he
releases some water inside the
iss
and you know i mean are we saying that
this never happened that this is all
green screened is that how they did this
is that the physics behind all this that
um she's just floating there and pulled
with wires each one of her hairs is
probably being pulled with wires maybe
they have a i don't know a ventilator
blowing her hair out
how did they do this please explain the
mechanism how they filmed this so that
so as to convince you on top of the fact
that she's floating okay
and uh here was the other fella you know
this was the same you can see he's going
from one place to another inside the iss
did they do that all with wires
i mean in this little station
is it all green screened uh is this all
made in uh computer made uh photoshopped
or whatever how did they do this the
guy's floating around he lets go of his
um
you know his um
tv there his little thing his uh
computer let me make this smaller sorry
make it a little smaller
so you can see what the guy is doing
there okay
okay he let's go of his uh his little
computer there okay
and you can see it's floating
so how did they do that plea please
explain the mechanism i want to know the
physics behind this you know i like to
do it myself
okay so yeah i don't believe that this
was done
in a um
in a in a gravity scenario this was done
in non-gravity and that's what the iss
does so to think that this was that this
guy's not in the iss well where is he is
he in hollywood is this being all done
with strings and and wires is that what
this guy really thinks
okay so this is this is real
okay and uh
if if you don't believe that do you
believe this okay here's this guy again
he's in this airplane that uh takes a
given curve at a certain speed a certain
angle and the guy floats for 20 seconds
in the air that's it 20 seconds after
that he falls back down because this is
not an astronaut this is uh what is
known as a pilot in other words people
who fly within uh
airplane level they're known as pilots
only when you go to a certain level are
you known as an astronaut so these are
pilots flying in an airplane and this
only lasts 20 seconds so you can do this
for 20 seconds the guy you just saw a
minute ago he did it for 45 minutes
straight
so to say that you know that never
happened that that was that that's a
hoax that that's all done with
uh wires and strings and whatever
now you got a problem you got a serious
problem
okay here's uh
here's another oh i fell to the other
side give me a second here
here's this astronaut he's jumping on
the moon
now could this have been done with wires
and
uh you know you can see him floating
around you say well
could have been done by wires no doubt
about it you know uh you know it's a
possibility
and you know what i did was uh run it at
twice the speed and here it goes at
twice the speed
okay
so all you have to do
i mean this this is obviously you know
you could do this on earth
and then uh slow it down
you know for uh to convince people
you know here you see it slowed down
okay we can do this on earth this could
be done in a um
in a uh studio
i have no problem believing that this
could have been done
uh here on earth
but not the astronaut going from one
room to another with his little computer
floating around
how do you do that
so no that guy was in gravity in a
gravity of zero gravity not only was he
in zero gravity he was in zero gravity
for 45 minutes straight
don't tell me that was done in hollywood
okay
okay and uh
so here we have uh
this is uh buzz aldrin this was on uh uh
apollo 11 okay
and he's doing some push-ups or like one
of the guys in houston so i didn't know
if you did a pull-up or a push-up there
you know because or chin up you know
because he says uh
he couldn't tell but you can see he's
floating around okay was this done by uh
hollywood for nasa is that how this was
done
okay this one maybe we can still believe
okay how about this one let me show you
this one okay here we have it
ah
close to the other side give me a second
okay here's a flashlight and buzz aldrin
just lets go of it
okay
and then he steadies it and you'll see
what happens to the flashlight it moves
very very slowly
and also check to see where he grabs the
flashlight
uh he grabs it from places where
you would think that there are little
threads okay he pushes it okay
uh is that being hung by threads from
different places because you're gonna
see that flashlight move around in
different directions in fact a troll
around how does he do this trick
here on earth
did he do this in a studio
and um
here's an even worse trick here's the
standing flashlight
okay and watch it how it slowly very
slowly
you know goes uh from you know stands on
its head
how did they do this trick
even today how do you do this trick in
uh if unless it's in a gravity
uh not a zero gravity uh scenario
okay you can see it's going slowly
and uh i said okay let's see if it's
true because see for the astronaut that
was jumping i said okay i double the
speed and i can show that
very easily that that could have been
done on earth no problem at all
what i did with this was you know very
simple you can do this trick at home as
well okay we have a little my my magic
wand okay
and you know if you stand this up and
let go of it it falls immediately it
does throw around but then immediately
it stabilizes it it doesn't stay like
this like in this case the flashlight
stayed like this for quite a while
okay i can't reproduce that with with
this trick here so how did he do the
trick tell me the physics behind it okay
that's what i wanted to understand
now you could say well he didn't go to
the moon he was in earth orbit
great that's what i wanted to hear
because he's got to be out there in
space somewhere he's either going to the
moon or he's going around the earth okay
those two i can accept to say that
aldrin was here on earth in a studio and
this was all filmed in studios with the
lights
from everywhere
now you're going to have to explain that
one to me show me how you do that in a
studio with the lights and with whatever
you want okay
so don't tell me that this guy was not
in space that's my point okay this guy
was in space whether he was in orbit
around the earth or going to the moon
that part can be debatable what is not
debatable is that this is not done in a
studio okay this was not photoshop which
did not exist at the time green screen
started by the way
after the 70s okay until then they had
blue screen and even before that 1898
100
years ago
they started with black screen they had
this black screen and they already had
invented it almost at the same time they
invented movies so we could do that we
can do that in a studio what we cannot
do in our studio some of the tricks he
did with the flashlight we can't do that
okay so
again you gotta explain it to me the
physics behind it okay don't tell me
that you believe or you don't believe i
need the physics i need the mechanism
okay
okay um
in fact uh some of the people who
rail against
you know
the um
the official version
they admit
that uh
these guys went at least into space in
orbit around the earth here it is let me
show it to you okay
pay attention
it is apparent they are in genuine zero
gravity aboard the actual spacecraft
necessary to convince the mass media of
their authenticity just not any further
than earth orbit
okay so buzz aldrin
he did a little trick there that's not
easy to do in hollywood okay even with
strings or wires or whatever okay
and uh and you can see that they're
saying there that uh it's
the guy was at least in earth orbit okay
and here they provide a little bit of
proof in that and that's that the way
they filmed the earth
from the capsule
is by not filming all of the earth it
was a nice little trick okay i want you
to watch carefully because again this
has to do with physics with how things
are done okay and here it is this is how
things are done
uh assuming you want to fool the public
and this could be one way they did it
okay so
again you got to keep an eye on all this
stuff because some of these arguments
are are
good to hear okay here it is okay let's
look at it
here you can see the extruded window
probably two inches thick at the bottom
this is because the earth shine is
coming in at a downward angle it also
causes the earth to appear to be an
irregularly shaped circle for you are
seeing the outside of the window at the
bottom and the inside of the window at
the top which together form two
different sized halves of a circle
subsequently this take was never used
[Music]
okay so what they did was film a portion
of the earth
and they used as a contour
the window of the capsule
okay
now was that done from the moon or on
the way to the moon or was that done
while orbiting the earth from relatively
close by
and just filming a portion of the earth
and making it look like it was a globe
that you were staring at
it's a valid question okay how did they
do the trick if they did the trick okay
and you know why did they show it well
that's something else that's got to do
with conspiracy but the physics of it
that is debatable that's something we
can
treat in this channel at least okay
okay so uh other issues that were
mentioned you know here and there a lot
of people mentioned here's one of them
uh the shadows okay when you look at
this from above
okay look at it from above here
you can see the shadows are
parallel but as he moves the camera
okay the shadows depending on the angle
seem to
converge they're not parallel anymore
okay look at it one more time
from above
and from a different angle and
below and again with a terrain that is
not completely straight
okay
so
you know shadows i don't know if that's
a good argument
because again people make too many
assumptions of what they think they
should be looking at okay
and here this guy can explain the
mechanism of why we see these lines
which are not parallel depending on the
angle okay
uh and again one of the things you don't
see is double light if there were two
lights
for example right
you should see two shadows
okay and that's not the case because
they see some shadows go this way the
other guy the shadow goes that way well
if you have two lights you should have
at least two shadows and you don't see
that what did they do rub them off the
film
so again how do you do this tell me the
physics behind it that underlies us okay
another one was the falloff of light
okay and here you see
what they're talking about they're
saying look you got a shiny part of
front and a darker part of behind they
have this falloff of light okay they say
what you should see is something like a
desert there you should see the sun
shining evenly across the whole
landscape
okay so they say this is proof evidence
you know that uh apollo uh 11 never
happened on the moon okay but uh here i
show apollo 15 okay here it goes
and you can see that they've got this
rover this uh golf cart going around the
moon and it's pretty even to be there
so are we saying that apollo 11 never
went to the moon but apollo 15 did
i mean how did they film this
double light
okay so again you you can't be
picky with your information you got to
put all the information down if you see
something that denies your theory you
should put it out there okay
and uh here you can see a comparison of
both of these okay
okay apollo 1169 on one side apollo 15
on the other
and you can see that the surface there
looks pretty much like that desert that
they film there
okay so i don't know uh i don't think
this is a good argument to raise and
that's one of the arguments that did
that the people who make the uh made the
film did make okay and i don't know you
you got to look at all data the one that
certifies your theory and also the one
that goes against your theory okay
okay so what can i say as a conclusion
uh you got to be open-minded that's what
you got to be okay and you got to be
available to think in different ways and
in different scenarios but here's here's
my conclusion for you for anyone who
wants to act as a detective to find that
objective detective to find out if the
moon stuff ever happened okay if he
wants to be honest with himself
first don't jump to conclusions okay
that's the first conclusion okay
then uh be rejected uh remove all
emotions people are very emotional about
conspiracies okay and you gotta stay
away and if possible from the conspiracy
and
focus primarily on the physics of it
how did they do it okay that's that's
what you really want to get to okay
even if they fooled you even if it's a
host you want to know how they did that
as well okay so how did they get to the
moon
okay
if they got there and how did they
make a hoax if they fooled you okay both
you have to explain the house in both
cases
um
you have to start by viewing things in
like most favorable to your opponent to
the other person's view
okay
uh be critical of your own theory okay
criticize yourself
don't just say oh yeah that's a hoax and
blah blah blah and just keep going now
you got to be a little more
paying attention to details and try to
see if you can draw uh make holes in
your own theory okay investigate what is
unclear
okay you know there's some things i
cannot explain and that's why
um
reserving a little bit of doubt there
because there are some things i cannot
explain just as simple as that
and uh don't throw the baby away with
wash water you know you don't reject
all of it because
of one little detail or whatever that
made you change your mind okay
i don't throw the whole
baby with a wash water
and what's my reasoning is that
we had all these intermediate steps okay
we sent first a rocket out there into
space at some point in time it orbited
the earth then they sent the dog then
they sent the men then they sent the
woman you know they went through all
these steps to say that none of that
happened that it's all a hoax you're
throwing away the baby with the wash
water you're saying well you don't
believe it blah blah blah but how do we
how is it that we have a space station
an iss a monster what is it uh tuna can
orbiting the earth how do we get it up
there
i mean are you just gonna say that one
day they just woke up and they said okay
let's put all these pieces of metal
together and just throw it up there is
that how it was done
so you got to explain all the steps that
led to the iss and that's when you're
going to find out that there were many
trips by rockets by probes going into
space
did we ever take pictures of venus of
mercury of mars with artificial uh
you know vehicles
i think we did
and so we do have rockets powerful
enough to take us to the moon certainly
to mars okay and uh i mean they have all
these icbms you know you think that they
can't go from
russia to the united states and from the
united states to china and so on of
course they can't
you know you think uh that can't happen
well i don't know i got news for you
you better sleep with an umbrella okay
okay let's move on to the subject matter
of today but i had to cover that oh
sorry guys who are lengthy discussion
there but
uh the moon landing is
pretty important stuff to a lot of
people and there's the physics part of
it that interests me and i think we
should cover that to some degree here of
course i'm not going to be as lengthy
with the moon landings in the future
but i do want to cover certain aspects
when something comes up if someone comes
up with some kind of evidence proof or
some mechanism really that's what i'm
looking for physical mechanism i'm going
to address it okay because i think it's
pertinent to at least to this channel
okay
let's go on with location what is
location well uh what we have here is a
fellow who asked a question related to
distance the other day specifically
distance traveled and he asked this uh
or he essentially tried to define what
distance traveled is he says the
distance of a moving object relative to
the medium it's traveling through okay
an airplane uses air to measure the its
distance traveled just as a boat uses
the water it floats in
okay so uh
what was my reply to this well i'm
saying that
you know physics doesn't deal with
measurement
and with distance traveled okay
especially when it's a numerical value
uh and so this was my answer said in
physics we don't measure
in physics we explain it's math that
measures and introduces numbers and
units okay
that's why it is absolutely necessary to
define what physics is about before we
begin to do physics it is the
mathematicians okay
which took over physics since the days
of the greeks that veered the discipline
in the direction of math this is the
reason not a single mathematical show
called physicists ever figured out
qualitative stuff such as mechanisms and
causes it's not part of their job
description even to this day by the way
yeah and yet why did they attempt to
provide a physical interpretation to
their equation in their in the first
place the answer is because otherwise
their equations are irrelevant
okay
if they're going to do measurement and
then they're going to
do an equation that somehow reflects
those measurements so far they have done
absolutely nothing that is of any
concern to science specifically to
physics they haven't done anything
that's of any importance of physics in
physics we need to explain the cause the
mechanism once we explain that we're
done with physics forever
physics science is not an ongoing
process of discovery no we stop and we
explain if you can't explain you're not
a physicist get out of the way and
you're you're
bothering us you're you're in the way of
progress okay you need to explain and
once you explain we're done with physics
we're done okay you got a better
explanation great bring it on
okay so uh how do we start this uh thing
where we ended up with distance and
before that i discussed um
uh
you know position
and um
what is it um
place
the other word the word that the
greeks use and so i started out with a
little summary of what happened in the
days of the greeks they weren't the
first by the way but they did uh
document what they thought about all
these things okay especially about
positions uh which a lot of people
equate with location today so let's make
sure we cover you know the steps that
led to that notion that position and
location are the same thing and it
started with these greeks okay
uh we had the iliadics there on the
upper left and they said that everything
is immovable there's nothing that moves
in the universe why because you know
there is no such thing as
an empty space in which something can
move into okay so that was the issue
so they said you know there's no such
thing as empty space everything is
covered when you move something
something else moves in there but the
only way it could move in there is if
you
had an empty space and they said that's
impossible so they said there is no
motion that was their conclusion
what did the atomists like democratise
and lucifers
come up with well they said well there
there has to be some space because
there's obviously motion in the universe
and so the they treated these other
folks as
idiots they said no these people are
saying there's no motion what do you
mean there's no motion i'm moving my
hand right now you know what the hell
are you saying there's no motion
plato thought that manner of space are
the same okay and so he said the
participant and space are identical so
he thought that space was a thing okay
and that matter kind of displaced space
the emptiness
and what did aristotle come up with well
he said the existence of lace is held to
be obvious from the fact of mutual
replacement okay you can replace
something in a watery where air was for
example okay
what now contains air for merely
contained water so that clearly the
place or space into which and out of
which they passed was something
different from both so he thought there
was um something
he called it existing
uh he that's the adjective he says it's
uh space this emptiness exists
it's a thing even though he said that in
order for something to exist it has to
have location
and so he said space exists and i don't
know what the location of space is but
he never answered that question he just
said it exists
and because it exists something can move
into space into nothingness okay okay so
that was his conclusion a few hundred
years later we have these three other
fellows i talked about them in the past
so i'm not going to go over them in
detail okay uh one was newton and he
said place is a part of space which a
body takes up and is according to the
space either absolute or relative okay
and he believed in absolute space and i
guess it was einstein who
turned that over and said no it's all
relative okay
positions property have no quantity okay
nor are they so much the places
themselves as the properties of places
okay so he started bringing numbers into
this where i don't even know what
quantity has to do with position
shouldn't have but you'll find out why
in a minute
and a short time later
less than a hundred years later we have
these two fellows human can't and
hume said you know space does not exist
independently of objects you know you
cannot conceive of space in the absence
of objects okay so this was his notion
so
you know again they were all trying to
figure out space and again position
i guess location of things in space
okay
and what did kant come up with well he
says he can't imagine the absence of
space
so he
the first guy said you can't imagine the
absence of objects this guy said you
can't imagine the absence of space
okay and so um he talked he thought
about in terms of infinite space again
he maybe he thought it was some kind of
object and he said well it's better not
to even think about these things because
we're not going to solve them okay
and yeah i think we can solve them if we
define what space is and once we define
space then maybe we can talk about
position and location okay so that's the
way it works in science and these people
never defined space and they started
talking about space without really
defining what they meant by space they
just wondered whether it's an object and
whether it exists
but they never started this square
number one which is please define the
word space if it's a concept and
otherwise point to it if it's an object
you know what is the shape of space
if you can't point to it then it's a
concept and you got to define it and so
they never did either so they didn't
start at square one that's why they
never figured it out and we're talking
about there at least the 18th century
okay did we do anything better since
then well then we have really made a
mess of things and here we have the
relativist and they said look we're
we're going to be doing length
contraction we're going to contract
space okay we just need to make that uh
thing travel at
uh the speed of light or close to the
speed of light and you'll see how it
contracts
okay like an accordion and what did the
quantum folks come up with well they
said space is made out of particles okay
it's uh got all this
junk in it uh one file called it the
direct c and his own name you know paul
direct uh and they say that particles
come out of the vacuum
okay in other words the vacuum is made
out of particles that can come into
our world they're known as virtual
particles momentarily okay they come
into our world momentarily these virtual
particles and then they go back to being
part of space in other words they think
that space itself is made out of
particles meaning that somehow they
equate this with an object with a thing
they're saying space is a thing
and so you can see the trouble that's
going to create for both position
and location you know because
how can you say that you have a certain
location
if you're what you're doing is taking
over the the spot
occupied by particles i assume are you
displacing the particles aside and
occupying
what
nothingness
if nothing else is made out of particles
what are you occupying are you
displacing the particles that make up
space
and if you travel close to the speed of
light are you shrinking or getting
taking up more space taking up less
space
what are you taking up if you haven't
defined what space is
so again we have a problem because none
of these people ever defined words what
was it what i said earlier i said that
you know one of the first words you have
to define in science is the word
definition itself you need to know what
a scientific definition is if you don't
define the word definition
uh then you can't even start
because you don't know what a scientific
definition is you're just going to go to
the ordinary dictionary pull a
definition out of there and say oh i'm
going to bring this into science it
sounds good to me
well if it sounds good be able to defend
it that's the way it works in science
here you can defend it against all
attacks
then uh you have a definition you can
use otherwise
you can't use that definition in science
especially for the foundations of
science
okay uh so what is position well
uh position essentially a game of
battleship that's what they think it is
today okay position
um is like a portion of space where
you're gonna put a dot in there okay uh
you're gonna put the not even a dot what
you really are putting is a an ordered
paired or triplet or whatever quadruple
you're going to put a couple numbers
that designate
uh how to get there how to get to that
spot
it's not the spot itself but how to get
there okay so they have a series of
numbers they say you know it's like
battleship you have
a h1 versus uh a
eight
and you put a dot there you put an x or
that if there's a battleship there well
you put a dot if you
have water there then you put an x great
it's it's the game of battleship that's
all it is
okay and so um uh what what is a
position under this notion this
definition or this
uh
way of presenting things in mathematical
physics and here it is it's essentially
how how to get to the treasure chest
okay what you have is in those two
numbers if you're using an ordered pair
what you're seeing is not the position
of something what you're saying is how
to get to that position you're giving a
set of instructions of how to find a
treasure chest okay that's what position
is under mathematics
okay so
here we have um
the way it's represented
they use the dot
to represent position
and again what they're doing there is
something which is irrational uh they
say that a position is defined or is
what they're going to use is a undefined
point they're going to say we're going
to put a point there well what's a point
well the point objectively is what you
see there it's a dot
it's got shape okay
so it's a it's an object under the
definitions of physics under the
definitions of science a dot is a thing
okay because it has shape that's the
only reason
and uh but a position is a concept
uh if if you take it as how to get there
that's a concept now you can use uh
something else like you can say well
what if i take the center of mass
of the
elephant what you want to do is locate
where that center you know the elephant
is an irregular shaped
uh thing okay so the center of mass is
not in its trunk or in its feet it's
somewhere in its body and so you want to
say what's the center of mass
of the elephant and there i'm going to
put a dot i guess but what are you
saying you're saying how to arrive from
a set of
coordinates a reference frame a frame of
reference from from that frame of
reference you're going to say this is 0
this is my starting point and i'm going
to go so many meters to the right maybe
on the x axis then somebody upwards and
that's how i get to the center of mass
of the elephant and you put a dot there
you know and you say okay that's the
center of
mass of the elephant again it's how to
get there it's not
like
you know uh i mean how else what else
what other
notion what other
definition could you have then for
position of the center of mass unless
you relate it to some frame of reference
and use in this case the x and y
coordinates to get there
there there is no other meaning to that
okay so position is you know how to get
there it's not
the dot itself that you're representing
in this case the center of mass of the
elephant what you're saying is how to
get to there to that place okay
that's what um
that's what this has become
okay so uh
what happens well if if that's what
position is okay
um is that the same thing as location
are we locating something
or are we talking about the position
occupied by either the elephant or the
center of mass of the elephant which
makes no sense whatsoever because it's a
concept you can't say the what is the
position of of the center of mass well
you can only tell the position if you
have an xy coordinate system and you say
so many feet this way so many feet that
way but if you just put a dot there what
is the meaning of that dot
okay it only has meaning if you put a
set of coordinates okay and so uh this
is this is the situation is position the
volume occupied by an object
are they synonyms the volume itself
occupied by i don't know the pencil
is is
is the pencil the same thing as the
position the volume it occupies or is
the position the steps necessary to get
there to reach
the dot or whatever you represented the
pencil with okay
because if it's b if it's the
steps necessary to get there then it's a
dynamic concept okay you're talking
about displacement you're talking about
motion
okay
meaning position which is a static
concept or in the minds of most people
it's
you know static concept
is actually motion because what you're
saying is i'm going to give you the set
of instructions of how to get there
take this road this way so many miles
and so many miles that way and you'll
reach the treasure chest
that's what you're saying you're giving
them a set of instructions on how to get
there
so it's not the volume occupied by the
treasure chest it's how to get to the
treasure chest
okay
so how do we do it in science well first
of all we distinguish position from
location okay
and the way we do it we have we have to
define them so position
is the volume the volume occupied by an
object
it has no importance in physics
because it's the object itself
okay
and we have no use for numbers
okay we
you don't tell me how many steps to get
there because it's irrelevant to the
issue that we're trying to resolve here
mother nature never went to school she
doesn't know anything about math
she's ignorant completely in numbers
mother nature just works with objects
every day she moves them around from one
place to another that's all she does
that she doesn't even do that what she
has really is every frame of the film is
what mother nature does location that's
all it is an object at a
given distance from all the others in
the universe so mother nature lives what
we can say in the noun
now meaning just a cross cross-section
of time not an interval of time i don't
care how small you want to make it an
interval is many many frames no matter
how you look at it we're not talking
about many frames of the movie we're
talking about a single frame
of the universal movie a cross section
of time so to speak whatever's in there
is static nothing is moving all we have
is distance between objects we call that
location mother nature only understands
location she doesn't understand numbers
she doesn't know anything about meters
and she only knows about separation
which was the distance
between objects separation
distance traveled no mother nature
doesn't understand that either
especially if it's numerical okay
because for that you need several frames
of the film okay and mother nature just
lives
at the cutting edge of
the past you could say you know right
where the past meets the future we call
that the now the now is not an interval
even though you know it's uh
you could think of it as an interval of
time but no the now is the cutting edge
it's a cross section of time it's a
single frame of the universal movie
everything is static there and that's
the only thing mother nature understands
so location is qualitative only what is
it well in order to get to the
definition of location you need to have
these words defined first you need to
know what an object is without objects
you have absolutely nothing in the
universe meaning you only have space
which is nothing which is that which has
no shape so you can't
nothing is happening nothing nothing you
can measure for sure there's no distance
no location no anything because you need
the object to have any of those
properties
once you have the object okay now you
have distance what is distance this is
just separation between objects
you don't unroll the measuring tape and
say it's so many meters that's not this
that this is traveled by the tip of your
measuring tape
we're talking about only separation
between
the centers of the object the surfaces
whatever you want doesn't matter that
depends on you but it's separation
once you have separation from this
object to that object to all other
objects then you have location now you
have the set of distances the set of
separations from one object to all the
others
so far these three
words are static concepts they only have
relevance in a single frame of the
universal movie in a cross section of
time
that's location for you all right
so
yeah uh forget about
uh this notion of position position
efficient position means motion
synonym saying that you know uh
it's how to get there
that's walking that's running that's
flying that's swimming those are verbs
okay position is how to get there you're
not talking about a static concept and
for sure you're not talking about
position position
anybody's uh idea of that at least in
ordinary speech is that it's
a static concept
and these people transformed into a
dynamic concept but we already have a
word for that we call it motion
so what is this position nonsense
and even if you're going to put numbers
to it we call it displacement or you
know distance traveled
so what is position you know again no
meaning whatsoever if you just put a
pair of uh
you know
ordered pair or whatever xy
okay let's look at the questions people
made okay
and here they are when paul said if not
by evidence then why would anyone choose
your hypothesis over any other
hypothesis you're right choosing is
opinion
opinion has to do with religion not with
science
so
yeah evidence is part of religion okay
evidence has to do with convincing
persuading you
asking you to change your mind
recruiting you to the congregation
that's what it has to do with if
evidence is not needed then saying god
does everything is just as viable as any
scientific theory
exactly okay it's just as viable whether
you believe it or not it's uh it's your
uh personal problem but you know i'd
rather believe in god than in the space
time because that's even worse because
here you're saying that assuming you
know that's what you vouch for you know
what you're saying is that um here we
have this concept
and that's causing gravity or or
whatever
you know the time dilation or any of
those no no i'd rather believe in god
god at least i can imagine you know it's
that fellow there with a beard okay that
i can imagine i cannot imagine
space-time because space-time is a
concept and they represent it with a
fishnet
canvas you know trampoline
what sense does that make to represent a
concept with a with with a fishnet
okay so yeah if i had to believe
somebody would rather believe the guy on
the left but then again it's evidence
has to do with belief so we don't care
about that well how the way we do it in
science we say let us assume
and we can make an assumption that god
exists that assumption you can make
you cannot make an assumption that space
time exists okay because space time is a
concept and exists requires an object
that's why you can't use space-time at
all
to make your case for gravity okay you
used evidence to conclude that the
international space station is real
uh yeah because we weren't talking about
a theory and we weren't even talking
about anything just belief
so we were talking about religion when
someone mentioned uh that it's
conspiracy or politics or whether that's
what we were talking about that portion
of the
that segment of the dissertation had to
do with conspiracy with belief okay so
yeah i did use it for that not for
science okay let's put it in the right
context
if your theory predicts a new phenomenon
predicts then you go searching for that
phenomena no no only what was it an
idiot was the word that we used okay
that's the person who does predictions
and who go searching for phenomena that
are predicted we don't do predictions in
science and science we work with the
past with what happened we try to
explain what happened
if you
explain something that will happen
you're basing it
on experience
meaning the past and again you're
explaining the past you cannot explain
why something will happen in the future
you can predict it which is a
description you cannot explain it if you
can explain it you're drawing on
experience which is the past okay so we
cannot explain
the future
something that will happen we cannot
explain it if you can you're not talking
about the future anymore now you're
talking about the past you're talking
about your past experience people don't
understand that it takes some a long
time to understand that argument if that
phenomena actually happens then that new
knowledge can be used to make new
technology okay where do we put
knowledge and technology well
up your nose holes that's where we put
it there's nothing to do with science
okay so
uh this notion about
making technology you know we do that by
trial and error has nothing to do with
science sciences explain the mechanism
knowledge what was the one of the words
in the idiot list knowledge when you
know
uh you believe and when you believe
you're not doing science so don't bring
that word into science
okay here we have uh another father he
says there is no reason more than
chemical interactions as to why what how
so he's saying that um
gravity works by chemical reactions
is that how gravity is is this a
chemical reaction
okay is that what the why that underlies
magnetism
my god science must be useful no no it's
a technology which is useful not science
science is useless
hopefully it's useless because the only
purpose of science is to explain so that
we understand that's it if you can make
some use of that well that's your
go with technology we don't care about
that science is not supposed to be
useful science is only supposed to be
understandable okay and to be useful it
needs to be supported by evidence again
religion
okay evidence is a an element of
religion because you're trying to
convince the jury you're trying to
persuade you're trying to change their
mind you're trying to get them to vote
for your version of
uh events
science does help with technological
development i don't know if it does or
not it shouldn't it's not its purpose
that's not the purpose of science the
purpose of science is to understand try
to please understand before one of us
dies as
mr faulty would say john cleese
okay what if every time instead of
saying magnetic field you had to say the
electromagnetic double belt helix uh
ropes that connect every atom to every
other atom now this is not a question of
semantics of saying i'm going to make
life difficult on you because i'm going
to put this long sentence that you have
to replace the word field every time now
you need to understand that field is a
concept there's no physical standalone
object called a field you can't say the
field did this and paddle the charge to
the other side of the universe you
cannot use the word field as a baseball
pad okay so this is where the problem is
these people want to use field as a
physical object that's a field there
okay you have the magnetic field and the
electric field what do you what are you
staring at you're staring at vectors
what is a vector magnitude and direction
a number that somehow is pointed
somewhere
that's what you're seeing you're seeing
a bunch of arrows a bunch of vectors
perpendicular to each other that's what
we're showing there and they call that a
wave what is a wave of wave of vectors
wave of numbers that's what a field is
or a pair of fields in this case okay
no
rope is a thing
it's an object it's got shape go and you
can prove this to yourself very easy if
you want to convince yourself right if
you want to do a little religion
go to the hardware store and ask for a
field and see what they sell you
or maybe they put you away you know
bring the men with the white jackets and
then ask them for a robe and they'll
sell you something that looks more or
less like this yeah what you see there
so yeah you can you can ask for a rope
because it's a physical object you can
ask for a field or a pair of fields
twine fields
they won't know what to sell you okay
can you order it for me
yeah maybe yeah
okay another palace says uh every
formula in physics which includes
constant
constant is false
okay formula he says anything that's got
a constant
is false okay why because there is no
constant in nature okay
the most accepted constant pi you know
3.14 la la la
is not a constant since nobody can
determine its exact value
so this vowel says that none of those
constants you know the uh
mass of the electron or the proton uh
you know the planck constant none of
those are constants because uh they have
as they say infinite numbers meaning you
can count incessantly or put incessant
number of decimal points or whatever
so he says it's uh there's no constant
and
we're going to destroy his religion
right here now
okay and it's that uh we don't need to
do any math we don't need to do any
measurement
to figure out that there is a constant
in nature
and that is
the torsion along uh a rope
an electromagnetic rope or any rope for
that matter here we have a rope and let
me pull this out momentarily
so that i can show you this okay
here we have a rope
it's a fixed rope you can see the ends
of it okay so that's all that's all
there is
and you know i control it more make more
links each link smaller
you know the different the
inverse relationship between frequency
and wavelength that's what you're seeing
here wave
what we call link length
and number of links
meaning
you know the
frequency
and now we untorque it and now we have
fewer links and each link is longer i
always use the same amount of rope
there's no more rope than this
okay so yeah we can figure out why
light travels at 300 000 kilometers
whatever i don't care if it's 301 or 300
or 299 kilo
1000 kilometers per second it doesn't
matter to us the exact value all we can
tell you for sure is it's a constant
it's a constant speed because it's a
rope that's only changing
the number of links
and and the
size of the link the length of the links
that's what we're doing so uh yeah light
travels at a constant speed because
light is mediated by a rope once you put
the rope in there you can conclude that
if you do it particles
or or waves transverse waves or whatever
waves you know spherical waves
then you cannot reach any conclusion
then you're right but if you do it with
a rope you're wrong you know you're
simply mis misinformed okay so just keep
that in mind and yeah here you see the
picture again okay uh
for a given length of rope okay
you can have either
the same number you can have a given
number of links
and you have more of them if you torque
it more and you have fewer if you
untorque it
okay and so for a given length of rope
you can have different sets of links and
um
length of links link lengths as we call
it okay so yeah that's what happens with
light light travels at a constant speed
because torsion is fixed all you can do
is change the number of links in
exchange for the length of the link
period we're done
okay file says
uh time is not different from space
okay and i i guess you know again he
gets that from people like hawking there
stephen gawking
time is the measurement of displacement
of an object in time i mean that made a
lot of sense and yeah that's where you
get it from people like him who say in
relativity there is no real distinction
between the space and time coordinates
just as there is no real difference
between any two space coordinates yeah
for them it's all the same that's why
they uh they don't see any difference
between coordinates and
dimensions vectors it's all the same to
them
there's no different because they all
have magnitude and direction and they're
all dynamic
all of them you know and so
yeah that's why these people can't tell
the difference between anything okay
final issue could this rope theory of
gravity also be possible to happen on a
flat earth oh my god
oh my poor god uh no i cannot imagine
the sun and the moon there you know um
rolling around a flat earth why because
see ours is the only theory that uh can
explain okay why light why water and air
curve around the earth you can't do that
with relativity you can't do that
quantum mechanics string theory none of
those can explain a electric universe
they cannot explain that either
the john chappelle society none of those
people can explain it
the only reason that
water and air curve around the earth is
because the earth is a globe
and then every atom of air every atom
that comprises water is bound to every
other atom that comprises the earth
including other atoms of area and other
atoms of water like you see there so no
matter where you put that little red
bulb which is representing an atom it's
connected to all other atoms and of
course everything tends towards the
center of the earth
okay
and so how do you do that with the flat
earth there you have your flat earth
okay and uh what do you think uh the the
moon and the sun are just kites that you
swing around the
the ropes is that how it works
no the
gravity is uh
the only way you can explain gravity is
with spheres
okay that's why the entire universe is
composed of spheres primarily you got
some smaller objects like you know maybe
asteroids that have irregular shapes but
anything that has a certain size is
roundish
and it's roundish i'll tell you why
because
it was once a star
that's why it's round anything that you
see round out there was forged as a star
and what you're seeing today
is a cinder of that star
and with that i'm going to see you next
time bye